[Musique]
leur regard est souvent la seule chose
que nous sommes autorisés à filmer nous
ne connaissons ni leur visage ni leur
nom les forces spéciales ont pour
habitude de se dissimuler derrière des
pseudonymes une tradition de discrétion
qu'elles acceptent le prix à payer pour
réaliser des missions d'exception
issus des trois armées elles sont
devenues au fil des ans incontournables
que ce soit à l'occasion de mission de
renseignements d'action offensives
contre des chefs terroristes ou de
libération d'otages elles échangent avec
l'ensemble des services de
renseignements la fusion des
informations collectées constituent le
cœur de leurs actions facteur de
puissance les Forces Spéciales
déterminent aussi le rang militaire d'un
pays et dans ce domaine la France fait
partie d'un club restreint à l'occasion
des 30 ans du Commandement des
Opérations Spéciales le journal de la
défense vous emmène à la rencontre de
ceux qui cultivent audace et humilité
une immersion inédite à clichés fermés
[Musique]
donc là on est dans un cadre de conflits
interétatique ou un des pays à demander
l'aide de la France pour l'aider dans le
cadre de respect de la loi
internationale à reprendre le dessus sur
une rébellion menée par un autre pays
d'accord
ce que vous avez des questions sur le
scénario c'est bon pour moi
donc pourquoi pour l'instant pas
d'activité déceler aux abords du
bâtiment vers pour sortir dans la cour
et te mettre en bas
[Musique]
notre reportage au sein des Forces
Spéciales débutent dans le Sud-Ouest au
cœur d'une installation de l'armée de
terre unique en Europe le CTA pour
complexe de tirade adapté ce centre
permet d'entraîner jusqu'à 30 tireurs de
jour comme de nuit sur plus de 6000
mètres carrés il accueille toutes les
unités des forces spéciales de l'armée
de terre mais également les commandos de
la Marine nationale et de l'Armée de
l'Air et de l'Espace des opérateurs du
raid et du GIGN ainsi que certaines
unités d'élite étrangères
le CTA nous permet de faire un pâtir 360
en munition réelle et notre mission
aujourd'hui était de récupérer une HDI
donc c'est arrivé individuel et
ce qu'on peut nous demander comme
mission par exemple sur le sel
ces hommes du premier régiment de
parachutistes d'infanterie de marine
partent bientôt en opération leur
passage ici est une ultime évaluation
dans un monde instable l'entraînement de
ces unités discrètes et réactives est
une priorité la cabine les Forces
Spéciales a été créée en 2015 et
aujourd'hui forte d'une trentaine
d'hommes sa mission et surtout centrée
sur la formation des équipiers des
forces spéciales mais aussi du personnel
de l'armée de terre qui est destiné à
armer le gaoss donc le groupement
d'appui aux opérations spéciales on
forme dans un panel de disciplines qui
est très varié qui va du de la de la
santé donc du secourisme au combat des
formations de cursus et d'adaptation
pour nos officiers nos officiers la
conduite le véhicule Forces Spéciales le
pilotage des drones le guidage aérien de
niveau très avancé
[Musique]
ales à
maîtrise de certaines techniques ainsi
que des missions telles que la
libération d'otages le contrôle
terrorisme maritime ou la capture de
criminels de guerre elles agissent dans
le respect du droit des conflits armés
et nos perd jamais clandestinement
à leur tête le général Bertrand toujouze
nous le retrouvons ce jour-là sur le
tarmac de la base aérienne d'Orléans
Brissy à l'occasion de la tournée
mémorielle du C160 Transal après plus
d'un demi-siècle de service cet avion de
transport s'apprête à prendre une
retraite bien méritée le transat c'est
beaucoup de souvenirs pour nous un
certain nombre de posés d'assaut assez
mythique sur pas mal de théâtres
d'opérations ce sont des choses moins
connues et parfois assez héroïques
l'appareil qui a marqué l'histoire de
l'Armée de l'Air et de l'Espace a
également été un outil privilégié pour
ce que l'on appelle communément le COS
le commandement des opérations spéciales
le COS en réalité c'est deux choses la
première c'est un état-major un état
major de 150 personnes qui est donc à la
responsabilité de conduire un certain
nombre d'opérations particulières pour
lesquelles il a été mandaté par nos
autorités principalement chef de major
des armées mais évidemment sur sur une
décision politique Hamon donc ça stricto
sensu le cosse c'est ça en réalité quand
on parle du COS on intègre également
l'ensemble de la communauté des
opérations spéciales l'ensemble des
unités et quand on prend l'ensemble des
unités on est actuellement de l'ordre de
4500 personnes c'est dans l'Écosse
également que 113 les commandos marins
l'entraînement les dispose à ses combats
arbres qu'il faudra livrer parfois avec
succès parfois sans espoir si en 1941
les premiers commandos marine français
s'entraînent déjà aux côtés des forces
britanniques sous le commandement du
capitaine de corvette Philippe Kieffer
il faut attendre 1992 au lendemain de la
guerre du Golfe pour que le ministre de
la Défense de l'époque Pierre Joxe
décide de créer une structure unique
pour coordonner les actions des
différentes unités spécialisées dès lors
et depuis 30 ans les forces spéciales
ont su s'imposer comme une capacité de
premier plan capable de gérer des
opérations sensibles avec des effectifs
restreints
pour faire simple on reste vraiment
engagé en général sur trois piliers donc
vous allez le monde de la lutte contre
le terrorisme qui continue de constituer
aujourd'hui l'essentiel des opérations
du COS parce qu'encore une fois l'armée
française reste assez engagée au Sahel
et nous continuons d'avoir des
responsabilités assez importantes
également au levant au sein de la
coalition qui est déployée en appui de
nos amis irakiens et des pays de la
région donc ça reste à l'instant T
l'endroit où le COS a impliqué le plus
grand nombre de personnes ensuite
deuxième sujet qui est important c'est
justement toute cette zone grise
début de contestation et là on voit bien
qu'on ne se tourne plus tout à fait vers
les mêmes zones à s'en rentrer dans les
détails très clairement ce sont des
réalités qui nous ont imposées depuis
quelques années d'être davantage présent
en Méditerranée et en Europe et sur la
crise actuelle évidemment nous avons des
intérêts et des enjeux très spécifiques
en Europe de l'Est troisième point le
cosse reste quand même capable de
s'engager
de la gestion de crise ponctuelle donc
doit avoir toujours également cette
capacité de force de réaction permanente
donc l'ensemble des unités du COS un des
trois armées et pour la chefferie santé
aussi maintient des modules d'alerte en
permanence avec un engagement aussi
dense rare sont les moments où le
général peut échanger avec ses
opérateurs ce dernier saut à bord du
Transal est une opportunité qu'il saisit
bien volontiers
c'est un moment privilégié pour
rencontrer les unités quand même et voir
les gens sur le terrain parce que
j'essaye d'aller sauter dans les unités
à tour de rôle pour que ça c'est une
autre façon de voir les gens donc ça
c'est essentiel et ça pas de prix
[Musique]
nous quittons une base aérienne pour en
rejoindre une autre en Gironde à Cazaux
les forces spéciales de l'armée de l'Air
et de l'Espace organisent leur
rendez-vous annuel majeur au programme
de l'exercice Athéna des scénaris
complexes rassemblant des commandos et
des équipages français espagnol et
américains un objectif certifié les
détachements qui seront engagés
prochainement d'opération au profit du
COS
depuis 2018 en fait il a passé une autre
dimension en intégrant toutes les unités
Forces Spéciales r mais aussi des unités
référentes de l'armée de l'air qui œuvre
on a pu des forces spéciales et des
unités modules d'appui aux opérations
spéciales qui qui renforce aussi nos
détachements en opération donc voilà on
a étendu à pas mal d'unités au sein de
l'armée d'air et une dimension aussi
intérieure armée interallié avec la
participation des forces spéciales terre
marine et aujourd'hui sur l'exercice
nous avons deux détachements étrangers
un détachement d'abstock Air Force
péchool Ops common avec un M6 130J un
avion ainsi qu'un détachement espagnol
composé dans le détachement commando et
des impacts et d'un équipage de casa
cn295
avec le retour des rivalités de
puissance les forces spéciales ont
densifié leur relation avec leurs
homologues occidentaux afin de renforcer
leur interopérabilité et c'est justement
avec un Hercules américain que cette
équipe âge des forces spéciales
françaises va s'entraîner à une manœuvre
délicate le ravitaillement en vol
[Musique]
et de regarder si le panier en bon état
voir s'il y a pas des problématiques et
de sentir neurologie derrière l'avion et
une fois qu'on fera stable et on
décidera d'aller chercher la pression de
ravitée
cette capacité que l'escadron
hélicoptère 1/67 Pyrénées et la seule à
détenir en France permet d'augmenter la
longe des opérations de pouvoir aller
dans la profondeur et de rester plus
longtemps sur zone pour soutenir des
commandos au sol
l'exemple d'une armée aérienne qui offre
des avantages tactiques opératifs et
politiques décisifs
s
sur le m630g américain pas le cap
hivernal
et le C130 français qui est sur Orléans
qui peut être sur place à compter de
17h30 blocs quand elle besoin
à réfléchir à des modes d'action
d'insertion d'infiltration donc on a un
aérodrome à hangar sur l'aérodrome sera
intéressant de savoir d'ailleurs ceux
qui pose quel serait aussi les
itinéraires entre les deux entre les
deux zones néanmoins de l'exercice une
nouvelle mission se profile une cellule
dédiée à l'analyse et à l'exploitation
du renseignement multi-sources récoltées
et reçu a permis de localiser un chef de
guerre celui-ci s'apprête à recevoir une
cargaison d'armes chimique pour le
commandement l'objectif est simple le
capturer avant qu'il ne change de cache
les commandos commencent alors à
élaborer leur
alors là du coup on a plusieurs
hypothèses pour la mission de ce soir
donc une première hypothèse qui se
ferait comment dire une mise en place
tout par par
USB donc un saut en parachute deuxième
hypothèse ou il y aurait
une première partie qui passe sortirait
en parachute et deuxième partie qui
arriverait en hélicoptère et une
troisième hypothèse pour la mission on
ferait tout en véhicule donc en fonction
de ça on essaie de faire une timeline
qui permet de séquencer un peu tout ce
qui est la phase entre la phase
préparatoire la phase d'action pour
après essayer d'affiner au maximum les
durées d'action ou de préparation
d'accord donc là faut tout anticiper et
faire les trois scénarios possibles ça
c'est bon et comme en opération réelle
ils doivent prendre en compte de
nombreux facteurs tels que la météo ou
la disponibilité des aéronefs et ensuite
convaincre leur hiérarchie
je commence à rédiger mon idée de
manœuvre pour le Connor
alternative c'était blanc mais on reste
en forme
Bruno et le chef du détachement du
commando parachutiste de l'air numéro 10
pendant l'exercice il endosse la
responsabilité de chef tactique déployés
sur le terrain on a une vraie phase un
peu une vraie nébuleuse au début avec
une situation tactique qui n'est pas
forcément claire tout de suite des
ordres qui sont en cours de construction
d'élaboration donc mon rôle ça va être
d'anticiper ça de voir avec les
différents chefs d'éléments hélico drone
c'est un process itératif qui fait qu'on
fait régulièrement des points de
situation on recale un peu les Giraux
comme on dit dans notre dans notre Fargo
pour pour avoir un produit fini compris
et partagé par tous pour mener Bruno
pourra compter sur un groupe Action du
CPAS 10 un Hercule et un twinoteur de
l'escadron de transport 3 61 Poitou
ainsi que des moyens de l'armée de terre
un groupe Action du premier RPIMa et 4
machines du quatrième régiment
d'hélicoptère des forces spéciales
depuis plusieurs années c'est que on
travaille avec les marins avec avec les
légendes du premier bon ça c'est on va
dire c'est un socle de base mais on
arrive à travailler que les équipes qui
vont être engagées avec nous donc là on
gagne vraiment en opérabilité à court
terme et à moyen terme sur l'opération
OK
moi ce que je veux c'est ma marge
habituelle ok ma petite demi-heure du
capitaine si on peut être à
00h30 minuit 40 dans sur zone c'est cool
juste un dernier rang ce qui est tombé
des partisans qui sont sur zone locaux
qui ont pris en photo
la zone du hangar Marseille 01 du coup
j'aurais deux véhicules et ils ont au
moins vu un PACS ça c'est apprendre
quand il y a deux véhicules dont
probabilité de finance les commandos
vont réaliser une infiltration sous
voile en un mot ils vont sauter à haute
altitude et dérivées sur plusieurs
kilomètres afin de s'insérer en zone et
demie pour l'équipage de l'escadron de
transport 3 à 61 Poitou c'est une
formalité cette unité est spécialisée
dans les infiltrations l'aéro largage et
les poser d'assaut
[Musique]
et tandis que les commandos atterrissent
en toute discrétion le C130 Hercule se
prépare à redécoller pour utiliser une
autre de ses capacités
[Musique]
donc c'est c'est le cumul savant au sein
d'un même aéronef des capacités de
commander le contrôle et d'appui
renseignements elle se base
principalement sur des capacités de
transmission chiffrer naturellement et
parallèlement la mise en oeuvre dans le
capteurs renseignements notamment
optronic qui permettent de déceler à la
fois les positions ennemies amis et
d'appuyer la manœuvre par ce type de
technologie
notre équipe de tournage n'a pas pu
suivre les opérateurs restés au sol nous
avons donc reconstitué l'assaut à terre
les commandos vont progresser à pied sur
4 km une phase pendant laquelle ils sont
en lien permanent avec l'appareil du
Poitou à une heure du matin le top
action est donné pour le groupe du CPAS
appuyez par les équipiers du premier
RPIMa les hélicoptères du quatrième rhfs
rompre la bulle de silence pour couvrir
le secteur 4 et demi sont neutralisées
et le chef de guerre capturé
le mode d'action donc un postériori a
fonctionné c'était peut-être le bon il y
en avait d'autres mais on a joué
celui-là il a marché malgré beaucoup de
changements et ça a été appréciable pour
les opérateurs mais également pour les
la cellules de commandement qui a fait
s'entraîner se rôder au processus de
conception de conduite des opérations
des soldats c'est aussi dans ces
moments-là qu'il développe un sentiment
de fraternité indispensable pour
affronter leurs engagements la meute
trouve son équilibre dans les groupes
qui sont anciens et qui sont qui sont
bien ça permet en fait simplement si on
si on doit comprendre ce qu'on vit de
tolérer de faire quatre mois par an ou
indésiens
loin du confort etc pendant 20 ans des
fois donc il y a forcément quelque chose
de du domaine de l'incroyable de magique
qui se passe dans ces groupes il y a des
suppléments d'âme partout on sent que la
cohésion
est de plus en plus forte à l'approche
d'une mission parce que il y a une
application qui est différente une
implication déjà professionnelle mais
aussi humaine parce qu'on sent qu'on va
avoir besoin des autres on va avoir
besoin de nos camarades sur le terrain
on sait qu'on peut risquer notre vie et
on sait que c'est eux qui vont peut-être
la également
ils savent aussi qu'ils seront épaulés
par des soignants spécialisés une
assurance pour qu'il puisse se
concentrer sur leur mission
de retour au CTA en pleine exercice un
groupe et 7 fois confronté à la
découverte d'un otage blessé par ses
ravisseurs
dans la doctrine du service de santé des
armées tous les blessés doivent être
traités de la même façon l'otage est
donc immédiatement prise en charge par
l'auxiliaire sanitaire du groupe
de la jambe gauche
un patient alpha donc les patients les
plus graves
il est blessé à la jambe et à l'abdomen
c'est des plaisirs graves très
hémorragiques pour lesquelles on va
devoir le conduire au plus vite auprès
du chirurgien
afin qu'il soit sauvé et dans le
meilleur état possible
allez tiens le coup c'est dommage on
s'occupe de toi t'inquiète pas ok
accroche
en mission les soignants doivent être
capables de délivrer des soins de très
haut niveau de la même qualité que ce
que pourrait faire un SAMU en métropole
qui va qui va aider à restaurer le
volume sanguin perdu tout en partant ce
qu'il faut pour que la coagulation soit
améliorée
dès qu'il sera prêt on le branchera au
patient et on s'occupera du prépa une
poche de sang pour lui passer du sang
pour compenser les pertes dues à
l'hémorragie le plasma lyophilisé qui a
fait ses preuves sur le terrain est une
invention du service de santé des armées
l'exercice de la médecine dans des
conditions atypiques pousse le personnel
médical militaire à chercher des
solutions adaptées
de l'hélicoptère
pour notre blessé la suite du scénario
va s'écrire ce jour-là par voie aérienne
un appareil du quatrième régiment
d'hélicoptère des forces spéciales va
venir le récupérer
[Musique]
le blessé c'est souvent le docteur qui
nous file les informations et en
fonction de la blessure du soldat mais
forcément on pourra plus pratiquer de
vol tactique donc faudra être assez
souple sur les commandes pour pouvoir
des fois pas non plus en altitier parce
que suivant les blessures qu'il a c'est
pas compatibles et après après c'est un
dialogue avec le dock le doc qui est
dans le foot en fonction de l'état du
blessé nous apporte constamment des
trucs à faire et comment évoluer quoi
voilà deux ans que le médecin principal
Clotaire fait partie de la première chef
du service de santé des forces spéciales
créées en 2018 comme lui ils sont 120
militaires de tout grade A intervenir
dans le cadre d'opérations spéciales on
n'a pas de particularité médicale nos
particularités vont être la un
savoir-être et un savoir-faire qui vont
nous permettre de nous insérer et de
suivre les groupes sans les pénaliser
et également la capacité à accepter des
situations qui nous mettraient dans un
inconfort médical tout en assurant le
même niveau de sécurité de soins pour
les combattants des interventions
particulières qui nécessitent une
sélection pointue il y a une campagne de
test annuels qui est ouvert à tous tous
les personnels du service de santé et
qui se déroulent sur plusieurs jours
avec des mises en conditions techniques
et et physique pour être sûr que les
personnes ayant un niveau physique
minimum pour être en mesure de suivre
les groupes sur le terrain et un niveau
technique en médecine de l'avant et en
médecine d'urgence nécessaire à assurer
les soins des opérateurs c'est bon on a
tous les gars oxy c'est bon imo leurs
entraînements réguliers permettent aux
équipes d'être plus efficiente en
mission quel que soit le milieu car si
les commandes au français sont bien
experts de la troisième dimension il y a
un autre domaine qu'il maîtrise
parfaitement à Lorient le jour n'est pas
encore levé quand ces hommes du commando
Jobert un des 7 commandos de la Marine
nationale prépare leur matériel pour un
saut à la mer en cas d'ouverture
intempestive du compteur principal après
le déploiement du RSE
on fait céder haut c'est spécialiste
doivent valider leur capacité à prendre
l'alerte dans le cadre de l'échelon
national d'urgence spécialisée dans le
contre terrorisme et la libération
d'otages
[Musique]
ici encore c'est un équipage du Poitou
qui est à la manœuvre ce n'est que la
septième fois qu'un largage de ce type a
lieu alors forcément chaque détail est
minutieusement vérifié toutes les
procédures y compris celles de ce cours
sont revus
on finit l'inspection par le haut du
bateau retrait de l'échelle on termine
l'arrière on s'équipe
[Musique]
au top la charge est tirée hors du C130
Hercule par un parachute éjecteur elle
est immédiatement suivie par le pilote
de l'embarcation et le chef de rêve ce
sont eux qui vont récupérer l'écume afin
de la préparer pour la mission
moins d'une trentaine de minutes plus
tard ils sont rejoints par le reste du
groupe par chance ce jour-là c'est une
mer d'huile qui les attend
ça qu'entraînement est l'occasion
d'améliorer l'efficacité parfois
l’équipement de ses soldats face à des
adversaires dotés de capacité de plus en
plus modernes innovée est une nécessité
la force maritime des fusillés marins
est commando ainsi créés en 2019 son
fuscolab un dispositif d'appui à
l'innovation qui permet d'imaginer et de
mettre en œuvre rapidement des solutions
adaptées aux forces spéciales sur la
partie visite de l'instit Bretagne du
coup au niveau du drone de surface on
m'a pas vu non pas un drone mais nous
avons profité pour montrer tout leur
atelier de drone donc on a pu voir non
seulement les drones de surface mais
aussi ce qu'ils ont en terme de drone
sous-marin drone aérien et drone
terrestre donc il y a des collaborations
qui pourraient être envisagées parce
qu'il y a des unités ici notamment qui
faire qui sont très intéressés par leurs
compétences de de créer des drones de
bout en bout et sur mesure imaginez
comme une start-up le fuscolab accueille
deux officiers d'activent et des
réservistes mais également tous les
marins avec des idées et les résultats
sont là
on a développé un moteur hybride pour
nos petites embarcations donc hybride
électrique est thermique ça c'est
quelque chose qui est en cours de
développement on a aussi l'intégration
de foil sur notre embarcation rapide et
traco nous sommes en train de développer
un dispositif permettant de naviguer
sans GPS à base de centrales inertiels
et d'autres d'autres équipements
d'autres exemples de projets plus beaux
Tom up la confection de d'équipements
nous permettant de de d'optimiser
d'améliorer encore notre capacité à
aborder un navire en pleine mer
également des ça va jusqu'au
développement de fusil en ce moment le
point un fusil un fusil hybride et
toutes sortes de petit équipement
parfois issus de l'impression 3D qui
viennent qui sont des interfaces qui
viennent vraiment faciliter la vie de
l'opérateur des petits détails mais qui
ont des fortes valeurs ajoutées
là je décolle une pièce qui vient d'être
réalisée donc il s'agit d'un prototype
de planchettes pour les plongeurs de
bord d'une unité
[Musique]
faites incubateur de projets se veut
aussi être le lieu où les inventions
civiles et militaires infusent et se
rejoignent on travaille avec certains
industriels donc que ce soit des petites
PME on aime bien travailler avec des PME
local parce que c'est plus facile pour
les échanges et on peut se voir ici au
plus là mais on travaille également avec
des plus grands groupes on travaille
après avec les instances innovations de
des armées comme l'agence d'innovation
de défense que ce soit avec Viano
correspondant marine via la commission
d'innovation participative par exemple
aussi et puis tout notre communauté
notre galaxie à nous du fuscolab les
marins bien sûr et les autres forces de
la marine toute la partie civile les
universitaires la partie DGA et bien
évidemment le monde des forces spéciales
avec les autres composantes chacune
d'entre elles dispose de cellules
dédiées à la prospective et se retrouver
régulièrement notamment lors du sofa un
salon bi annuel organisé au profit du
COS qui permet à l'industrie française
de démontrer la pertinence de ces
solutions une clé essentielle à la
réussite des opérations
aujourd'hui l'entrée dans une aire de
compétition de puissance impose aux
causes de se transformer après 15 années
principalement dominées par la lutte
contre le terrorisme les forces
spéciales doivent réorienter leurs
entraînements vers des scénaris de haute
intensité et répondre aux défis
capacités auxquelles elles sont
confrontées une adaptation qui fait
partie de l'ADN de ces unités habituées
à faire autrement
[Musique]